talking about the deep urban army your  your fan for the sunday faith and what  we're in that army turn yeah yeah so  they come to your conference and they  demonstrate their loves in different  ways was there was a woman who wanted  you to sign her oh no I was a years ago  that are doing a concert in this big  venue and somebody in the crowd yelled  out when you sign my leg and I thought  it to be a good moment you know and so  I'm like yeah come on up here you know  if supposed to be great his years at  roadmap neck another this would be a  great make a great moment on stage and  so she disappeared  for a minute I couldn't see her head  next thing she reappeared and then  lobbed this prosthetic leg find it and  then I thought what's the correct  prosthetic leg returning etiquette  [Laughter]  I knit that crowd sets it back and  patched it was like  [Music]